nauru 2960
la france n'est encore qu'aux prémices
de l'énergie nucléaire et déjà des
interrogations sur la gestion de ces
déchets radioactifs des déchets
dangereux mais alors où les entreposer
comment les recycler le problème est
déjà vertigineux mais du côté des
autorités
aucun lieu de s'inquiéter tout est sous
contrôle les déchets qui sont hautement
radioactifs sont tous concentrés et ils
sont conservés sur place dans les
centres atomique même les déchets qui
sont de moyenne activité sont scellées
dans des récipients dans des fûts par
exemple et ils sont ensuite déposés et
il y a deux sortes de dépôt qui sont
envisagées actuellement des dépôts
terrestre soit la surface du sol soit
sous terre et des dépôts marais au fond
des océans
et oui vous avez bien entendu des
déchets radioactifs balancé à la mer
d'autres solutions avaient été
envisagées
l'enfouissement dans des mines de sel la
propulsion vers le soleil mais dans les
années 60 la france décide d'immerger
une partie de ses déchets dans
l'atlantique et dans la méditerranée des
déchets radioactif dans l'eau de quoi
inquiéter les français affaiblirait
précis tout de même les océanographes
aussi sonne l'alarmé
car ces déchets restent radioactifs de
nombreuses années et surtout l'énergie
nucléaire est en pleine expansion
ce projet pose des problèmes très
difficiles à résoudre
parce que évidemment nous ne savons pas
quelle sera la durée de ces containers
de ces récipients au fond de la mer
savons pas du tout s'il résisteront 10
ans ou un siècle
mais encore une fois le commissariat de
l'énergie atomique balaie toutes ces
craintes alors même qu'ils n'ont aucun
recul sur le vieillissement en mer de
ces déchets alors ces poissons
peuvent-ils être contaminés et par là
même disparaître un jour de l'inventaire
c'est une hypothèse invraisemblable car
la radioactivité des mères est
surveillée
et en tous les points du globe la france
arrêtera ses campagnes d'immersion de
déchets radioactifs dans les années 70
en effet l' usine de la hague est créé
pour vitrifier et stocker ces déchets
radioactifs mais d'autres pays
continuent ces largages
il faudra attendre les années 90 pour
qu'une convention internationale soit
signée l'océan atlantique ne sera plus
la poubelle nucléaire de l'europe
quatorze pays ont signé aujourd'hui une
convention dans laquelle ils s'engagent
à respecter cet océan aujourd'hui encore
la gestion des déchets radioactifs est
un problème sans solution satisfaisante
usine de la hague est saturé le
gouvernement se tourne alors vers
l'enfouissement sur le site de bure dont
la phase pilote devrait démarrer en 2025
les déchets ultimes seront alors en
fruits pendant des centaines de milliers
d'années une bombe à retardement pour
les antinucléaires
[Musique]